I was bored in school.
Lots of us were and
when kids are bored and restless,
schools usually blame the kid.
1 in 5 high school boys diagnosed with ADHD
Millions are given drugs to try to make them sit still
I was the rowdy kid, that was the bad kid.
So they really pressured my parents
to actually put me on ADHD medication
Adderall.
Yeah, Adderall, Ritalin...
it was like I had been lobotomized.
My parents said, "This is not our son."
They then sent him to other schools.
he hated them all.
I would come home and I would sometimes just cry.
What better things could I have been doing
during that time where I was just sitting
in a classroom having information chucked at me.
So what did you do?
I left.
He left because he heard about a school
that teaches in a different way.
Like ok how do we actually increase our knowledge?
The school is the Academy of Thought and Industry
but the school costs money.
I got a job at a coffee shop.
to work here he got up at 3 in the morning
by 3:30 he was in the shop setting up tables and chairs
cleaning the counters
I would get the bacon frying
get all the breakfast items ready.
Hard work just to go to this school.
Academy of Thought and Industry, it sounds Soviet.
I want my students to think with their minds
and understand the world and I want them to
get stuff done.
Michael Strong started the academy
by telling parents
“Kids learn better by doing actual work.”
Teens need responsibility.
Ben Franklin, Andrew Carnegie, Thomas Edison,
started their careers
at the age of 12 or 13.
Yeah, that was abusive child labor.
I worked as a teen.
I loved it.
At his schools, there are now two with more on the way,
Students get Fridays off
to work on their own projects.
there are no lectures
instead students read and discuss things.
Because they're still people
and people still have certain drives
That’s very different from schools Strong attended.
and hated.
School is 13 years of how to be passive
and how to be dependent.
The Republican controlled House of Representatives…
Sit still, read, listen to your elders, repeat.
Anyone know the effects?
School is about aim, aim, aim, aim, aim,
and never get stuff done.
So I want students who let's just go out there
get stuff done, fail, get up, try again...
That's how we become creators, entrepreneurs...
We want them to do what they love now.
Cade was given projects like: start a business today
Why was that more interesting than studying history?
Or going to science projects?
Because the money, because the money.
I'm currently working on making
a web-based chat application.
Students study what they care about.
I wanna be a programmer.
I love programming.
We got to create a project
and immediately start feeling the rewards of it.
I was doing a few sketches for the costume designs.
I actually work at a paintball place.
If they love paintball,
then they should do a business in that.
Dorian Domi started a music business.
At this point in my career,
I’ve booked almost 200 bands.
His music festival, brings in tens of thousands of dollars.
We have students who have done websites
for American Idol finalists.
These people use the website then as their own?
For about 9 months and then he fired the team,
a high school team, and got a better team.
That was a great experience for my students,
to get fired by a client
is actually a really good experience.
You do that several times and
that's how you get better at getting stuff done.
So companies hire Strong’s students.
Cade got a marketing job right out of high school.
At a place called Launchpeer
which I currently am at today.
People say, "You gotta go to college."
Well, look at me.
Most of Strong’s students do go to college.
We've had students be admitted to
top liberal arts colleges.
Bard, Bennington
‘course they do well.
You're charging fat tuition.
Only rich kids can afford to go there
and they're going to do well.
The kind of kids that we get come from all walks of life.
We had a student from New Jersey
he was incapable of functioning
in the highly structured public school system.
In middle school, elementary school,
I was, you know, incredibly socially isolated.
In the public schools he needed a full time aide.
He was costing the state an enormous amount of money.
He came to our school, he did not need an aide.
Coming here is just healing.
It's incredible.
So much so that some students
wake up at 3 in the morning
to go to work to help pay tuition.
It was me choosing my life